Buenas tardes los bloqueos y protestas
continúan en el Perú en la carretera
central que es en el ámbito del centro
del país en los campesinos han encendido
la alarma porque las manifestaciones
bloquean algunos tramos importantes de
esta vía y los productores de papa del
centro del sur de Perú no pueden
cosechar debido a estas interrupciones
en el sur del país en la región ica en
las últimas horas se produjeron
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas del
orden y los manifestantes que dejó como
saldo 10 policías y dos civiles heridos
a esta hora avanza una marcha en los
alrededores de la capital peruana pero
va con tranquilidad y donde las cosas Sí
están movidas es en el congreso peruano
donde un grupo de parlamentarios ha
Interpuesto una moción de impeachment
contra la presidenta Dina boluarte por
incapacidad moral permanente la
iniciativa responsabiliza la mandataria
peruana por las muertes producidas
debido a las protestas
necesitan 66 votos para que la moción de
vacancia presidencial sea admitida a
trámite